what sex ed if any did you get
sex ed are you kidding me
in mississippi
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self podcast
i am your host your roast coming queen
a girl who is kind of dressed like her
teenage self today elise morales and
with
us today guys we have such a funny
friend of the show
he is an actor comedian and podcast host
who you've read about in vulture and
seen on fallon colbert and hbo's high
maintenance
but before all of that he was a graduate
of william b
murrah high school it's jay jordan
hello go mustangs mustangs that's a good
that's a good mascot in a classic mascot
it's a good mascot because
you if you're cool for your 16th
birthday you can get
the mascot as a car i did not but other
people did
did you have a car in high school oh
yeah
oh yeah i had the first car i drove was
my grandmother's
no it wasn't a buick it was an
oldsmobile 88
that was the first car and my
grandmother wasn't driving as much
anymore so
that kind of became my car was
bequeathed to me
and then i got my very own 2005
mitsubishi gallant
wow yeah and so that was
was the um was the first car like would
you have to do the thing i always
remember this where you would put like a
cassette in and then hook the cassette
into your phone
to play a song i
got the system in that car
taken out and put in like one of the
little radio
faces got it but then it could do a
couple of cds
and it was like this was i mean i'm
gonna age myself this was pre
iphone ah this was
pre iphone yeah cuz like iphones didn't
come out until
my freshman year of college i'm trying
to remember because now that i'm
thinking about it like i wasn't
people didn't really have iphones when i
was in high school
either so maybe that's actually more of
a college memory for me though
i remember i remember the college
ox like adaptation court like the
adapter
in college so many cds just see the cd
cds
and so like i used a little bit of money
from work to buy like a new
radio for that car and then my
grandmother whenever we'd switch off
she'd be
she did not know how to use it at all i
effectively took a locked her out of any
listening to any sort of gospel on am
stations
oh no for grandma she's just listening
to your cds
just a lot of young jeezy that's it
you're gonna have to deal with this
sarah
okay so william b murrah high school
what uh
what flavor of high school was that is
like a
public school private school so it was a
public school
in the capital city of mississippi
but it was a public school with a couple
of like cool
additions so i went to that public
school for high school
but i also went to a performing arts
school in conjunction
with that school system so i went to my
theater classes the last
two hours of the day
every day and was that like did you
leave campus for that yes oh wow
but but the theater building
uh for the scholastic program for the
for aipac the
um i want to say the performing arts
complex school it was
just down the road so when you could
drive
you could you had enough time to go to
the closest wendy's and then
come back so you could get wendy's in an
embrace which was like when you were
when you finally had a car or when you
were like friends with people that had a
car
you always went to wendy's like you
always if you had enough time
you could go even further and go to like
this
very local southern chain called
backyard burger which was like
so it's just like a mississippi burger
joint
but you could go to either one of those
places and then you'd be like the cool
junior senior walking in
with like food yeah for us that there
was a
like shopping center nearby that had a
chipotle and a noodles and company
and like if you walked into school with
the chipotle it was like everyone would
know
like yeah oh my gosh they went off they
went off campus
they don't care about the soft
rules they
purchased lunch so
i um so i was part of the uh
theater program and i've been doing
theater since i was
12. so i went through all of middle
school and all of
uh high school doing that and so in
middle school you attended your theater
classes in the morning
and then you got bust to your respective
middle school like two hours like an
hour or two hours later than everyone
else
and then in high school they flipped it
so all your stuff happened at the end of
the day
so i mean this is in many ways uh a
theater kid podcast so you gotta you're
gonna
you're gonna have to take me through
what are the jade jared and major roles
oh my god okay so when we did the
outsiders
your boy played emilio estevez's
character in the film version two bit
i wore i wanna say
i wore like uh it's like
just a white t-shirt and denim jackets
or like a denim vest like that whole
sort of vibe
but so that was like a fun role at one
point
outsiders is a classic middle school
moment
outsiders if you don't do if you don't
do
outsiders in high school or middle
school
then i don't know what you did
like what what did you learn about if
you yeah how you don't know about soda
pop and dairy and johnny and dallas
all this i mean i remember watching the
movie though
that's a sexy movie to put on
for a group of middle schoolers it also
it shows you what money can do because
you get to see
tom cruise's real teeth yes
tom cruise's real teaser in that movie
and don't they
don't they make a comment about like
cherry there's that girl
yeah make a comment about her like if
she has red pubes
too yeah like so yeah well because like
the whole like
like the socials they were like the
social girls but then like
the reason that the greasers were so
attractive
is because like they were gonna [ __ ]
none of that was lost on me when i when
we watched that movie
i did that when i was in high school and
then
senior year i wrote a bunch of sketches
for like a thing that eventually i guess
proved that i should pursue comedy
like 15 years or however 12 years later
and then i
um what else went really
what else was like a lot of fun oh you
so you just you do
i did the wiz i was the wiz in the wiz
richard pride
i was linda and wizard of oz okay yeah
yeah
and we double cast so there was also i
just
for the sake of fairness there was a
white wiz too but
everyone was like jay um we
like you doing it more but we did have
to double cast this i was like that's
fine i don't care
that's very fun and the line which in
the wardrobe was
like kind of like a much bigger cast so
they had to
get some high school kids and some
middle school kids
so they were like i want to say our lucy
was a middle schooler
and our edmond i think peter
and this other sister were high school
freshmen but i was mr tumnus
so i did i mean i worked i booked
i was booked in high school yeah i'm
like teenjay is booked busy and blessed
he's got a lot on his plates yeah
it would be fun to start putting that in
as people
like as people have you on shows to be
like you've seen him as mr tumnus
yep elise first show back
you might be like uh yeah you can say
like whatever
you uh could you say that i was two-bit
in a
high school production of the outsiders
in jackson mississippi thank you
and that i was good oh that was
hilarious
so okay let's talk about uh teen j's
social
life so were you friends with other
theater kids or was that more a
professional
thing for you and social life was
separate i
hate that this has become a ryan murphy
podcast but
i was lucky enough
to be friends with theater kids and like
football kids
and like some ap class kids so it was
it was kind of like a a good mix an
eclectic mix the high school was
probably like
80 black and then like 15 15 white
and then 5 other and so
because i was in ap classes
like there were a lot of people that had
a bunch of extracurriculars because if
you're already taking ap
classes then you're going to do extra
[ __ ] on top of that because that's the
kind of
personality that they've cultivated
since middle school for you
yeah so i was taking ap classes and so
you'd have the people that played
football
but also that did theater so one of my
best friends christian vance
he did both and that was like one of my
ends and this was like before you knew
you could do that so there were like
clear lines
of demarcation that you were like
breaking you were like this is the plot
of high school musical
oh yeah yeah he's like can i be
in the play and be on the basketball
team
no one knows if he can well they know
that's the weirdest part about troy
not knowing is that he
sings about basketball and you're like
so uh
dog yeah you don't basketball about
singing
so you know which one you like more
listen troy we can all see what's in
your heart babe
you made three movies i also
love that um oh my god vanessa hudgins
character what's her
gabrielle gabriella she's always vanessa
hudgens to me
um that her thing is like can i be in
the play and do
math oh oh my gosh
yes yes of course those two things
actually have a sacred
bond i was notoriously bad at math
wow okay this is why we
i built it i felt it digitally
through the internet which
famously designed by people who love
math uh
but i'm i'm not one of the folks no i
had um and i've talked about this on the
podcast i had an antagonistic
relationship with my algebra teacher
and um i mean my relationship with math
was not good before that but after that
it was just completely broken there was
a really cool math teacher at my high
school
i never took any classes from her but
she was
she was so nice to me kimberly van ooten
and she was super chill and everyone's
like oh jay you love
math if you took it with her and i was
like no i wouldn't
that's the thing is no i was like is
this still math
oh wasn't that yeah so that's that
that's the part that's kind of tripping
me up
not whether or not my teacher's cool
great cool i'm she's a very nice lady
it's like it would make it a more
enjoyable experience i'm sure but it's
not about
it's not that i'm not getting like a
good performance from my teacher
i hated it wasn't customer service for
me yeah i hated math
so much and loved the science that when
i took chemistry
i took chemistry and i was like you have
ruined science
you put all this math in here this is
actually math
i was like this is math they're like no
no you just got to find out how much
these things weigh
i was like you say that but there's some
equations involved
i'm solving for things i can tell we can
talk about the properties and
categorization and qualifications of
things maybe we can
even get in like some form changes but
once you start
making me solve for letters
don't i know what this is and that's the
and that's the real thing is you're
solving for letters
and my brain has never gotten around
that
once they started putting letters in it
was really downhill for me with math
oh yeah we i took i didn't have to take
math my senior year i think my
math my last math class was junior year
of high school
and i was taught by a man named
mr hamilton and it was trigonometry but
what it really was
was we just babysat mr hamilton who was
not a good teacher
at all his daughter also went to our
school
and his daughter was named gina gia or
gina
i think it was gia super pretty had this
like down to the middle of her back long
curly hair
and everyone was like oh gia your dad
is crazy
every guy who ever hit on her was like
man
i you're that we have to basically
babysit your father in this trigonometry
class and like make him
think that he's teaching us but also
what up
so what was his what was his behavior
like
so he he loved
math in a way that sometimes he would
just forget to give us homework
he would like he would be more
interested in making us
enjoy and love math so he
was one of those people whose passion
outweigh like
being a pragmatic math teacher so i can
tell you
with so much confidence that
i did not deserve the grade i got in
that class
yeah but i got it
so then i went to college and i had to
take math freshman year
it was like college algebra i think it
was i think it was freshman algebra or
whatever they called it
i uh i did so bad i used i had to use my
freshman forgiveness
you only got two of those as ole miss
where you get to replace a class
if you take the same class twice you get
to replace it with the highest
letter of grade that you got on between
the two and i did really bad the first
time because i was a freshman
and i also discovered marijuana and
mgmt shout out oracular spectacular
and then i had to like take it all over
again the next year
jay can i tell you that the exact same
thing happened to me at the university
of delaware
i failed my first math class i had to
use it as my one
take takeover and it's because me and my
friend tyler got high every day
i don't think enough people are saying
this
like yeah okay here's another confession
but this is from high school
for driver's ed permit test failed the
first one
i failed mine oh my god jay
failed it i failed it and lied okay so
i rolled through a stop sign i was kind
of herky-jerky
with the break and i was just nervous it
was
i'd been practicing where i lived but
then i didn't practice
where the test was going to be so it was
a neighborhood that
i just wasn't familiar with jackson is
notorious for having a bunch of potholes
and so they could just tell that i was
too nervous behind the wheel and i
failed it and i told people i was taking
the test that week
and so you know people asked and i was
like i actually i pushed it back
[Laughter]
it's in a few weeks i lied
oh you know what something actually came
up and i was we had to research every
schedule
you know how dangerous driving is okay
have fun with that
you know they've actually been begging
me to take the test i told them
yeah yeah yeah you know like man you
know how the dmv is i had to get back
here
and school y'all that's what i had to do
you're lucky
i think that i
probably i was a reckless driver also in
high school
there are there are a couple of side
mirrors not mine but other people's
r.i.p sorry and nobody knows
i'm i can talk about it now because it's
this is 2005.
this is you know 2004. people were
wilding out back then
but uh i was i'm so glad
i don't have to see 16 year old or 15
year old jay on the road right now
because i'd be like
what is he doing i was i was an
anxious driver i wasn't a reckless
driver but it made me just as bad as if
i was a reckless driver because i was
like constantly stopping and like
driving so slow
and like not confident at all like on
the highway and getting lost and turning
around so all
it would have been more fun if i just
so that's that's like um that's one
thing that i vividly remember
is like the parking lot of our high
school
there was a student parking lot and you
didn't get a parking spot until your
junior senior year and really seniors
design
got to like if you wanted to you could
like spray paint your parking
spot but you had to do that like i want
to say a week before school started
and a lot of football players and like
cheerleaders were already there because
they were doing practices and stuff
so they they would like get their stuff
done probably a lot of stuff happened in
the parking lot parking lot is also when
you found out that they were doing a
cell phone check that day
so you would leave your phone in the car
oh so they would check if you even like
had it on you
yeah so you would see people coming back
and you'd be like what's going to be
like oh they're checking cell phones
today and then you go and keep your
car your cell phone in the car wow i
wonder if they even can do that now
i feel like the kids today are like [ __ ]
you the kids today
they know too much yeah they're like
okay
technically my homework is on here
exactly exactly and they're like well i
actually already had my phone embedded
into my brain
so it's up here
they'll be like well i don't know if
these revealing pictures of my
teacher will have anything to say about
you like all right okay
yeah this is actually an emotional
support phone
yeah um i feel like
around the time like early 2000's high
school there was so
much panic around cell phones
but that's it there was a lot of panic
at the disco and i was right there
but there was so much panic i felt like
around cell phones
and like having them at school or not
having them
and also wikipedia everyone was so
scared that we were gonna be
learning from wikipedia not only that we
were going to be learning from wikipedia
but that a wikipedia
that was in its infancy with like
maybe that much information they'd be
like well you better not
steal you'd be like that a sentence
number one i'm not gonna plagiarize
because i know how to move words around
and i have a thesaurus
don't worry number two is this i can't
write my paper just off of that exactly
and it was like there was so much ire
from like i feel like
every year that we would meet in the
library at my school and they would be
like do
not write your papers based off
wikipedia and really go
okay they'd be like you have to go to
the library
go to this book and write your pages
write your papers from that book
yeah use our weird old search system on
our weird old computer
and find what you need oh and that was
like
as a person who actually enjoyed my
english class
that was one of the things where i was
like because
with english sometimes she'd be like i
feel like i am
just so far removed from what i'm
actually even trying to talk about
because i gotta go through
all these hoops to get to the research
papers of other people
yeah i i was it was so much time
learning to write a research paper which
is a skill
i am not gonna use a skill that
comedians use all the time i do yeah
or work cited at the end of every set uh
i do a whole bibliography
yeah well the way people reply to tweets
these days we might as well
yeah mla and we're always well actually
sources please i'm like okay sources
please
i said that i farted so loud today that
it shook
my apartment and they'll be like well i
would like to see some sources
that's actually not even possible it's
like okay
okay thank you all right
so tina let's get back to team j yes
is teen j dating and if so
who's he dating what what is he doing
with the people he's dating
oh my god okay
elise this is this is humbling
and i am i'm happy to
say this now my first
girlfriend like
important girlfriend in high school it
was
sophomore year no junior year
that was the big one junior year ended
up being a prom date
sort of situation and started dating in
the spring
she was a cheerleader well there so you
were a football to cheerleader
relationship so i no because i was still
theater i was friends with football
i don't have to play football at all i
i was close enough with the football
players that they would not
make fun of me to my face so that was
always
that was where you wanted to be yeah
because everyone's going to make fun of
everyone behind everyone's back because
it's high school but as long as like you
can go to a lunch table and say hey to
people she's like okay i'm good
yeah as long as you can like live in
peace from day to day
you just didn't want to be publicly
bullied that was it
so i had a girlfriend
we went to prom together and
uh adult listeners that does mean what
you think it means it was a very
american prom wow
yeah and that was i mean that was also
that was the v
card so yeah it was was it like all
planned out to be
did you go all the way of like planning
it out to be special no so like
her friend's mom was the
way that we got like the hotels for like
after parties and stuff because her
friend's mom worked at a hotel
which is like not good i listen i do not
approve of this parenting style now but
looking back on it
thank you that you know what thanks
so much to that friend's mom yeah and so
like so
this is so this is like kind of not it's
not really bad
so you go to prom junior year
and then after prom you go like a little
after party and then like we had like
our own
hotel after party and she was in the
dance program
at the performing arts school too
because she was a dancer
and so it was like one of those
situations where
i look back on that prom fondly junior
prom
was amazing senior prom oh terrible
oh no okay well we'll get that story in
a moment
oh my lord um so
you this was all arranged for like
after the after party oh yeah it was
like after you saw like
your friends after the after party
because like you go to prom
and well you you know this you go to you
eat first at some place
yes and then you go to prom and a
restaurant you think is fancy that you
think back on and are like that is not a
yeah that you literally look back on now
and you go
wow we were terrors
that poor weight staff why would we do
that to them
yes i mean literally getting into for
prom it was like
you'd get in a limo you'd get insanely
drunk
in the limo go to a restaurant terrorize
a restaurant
yeah get to your school get to your
school
terrorize people that have dealt with
you for the past
either three or four years yeah and
they're like
we can't even send these kids home
because
this is where this is we gave them the
space to do this
so we can't even be mad at them for
grinding all up on each other
we told them to do this we told them to
do this here
because we wanted to be safe under our
eyes look at us
nasty i know that's i if because i've
dealt with high schoolers at a distance
since like one time i had to like be
uh like a person who helped a theater
camp
for like i want to say two three weeks
and like their high schoolers there and
you're like y'all are
disgusting nasty i'm disgusted
not only do they smell they're like and
i know why we were described this way
because i've been described this way in
high school
it's like y'all are just like little
dirty puppies
yes all over each other that's it and
they're all just little
puppies look in each other's faces
and sometimes they get all excited and
accidentally pee themselves and you're
like oh god we gotta clean you up now
so he what i was dating
after i dated her there was another
cheerleader that i would secretly make
out with who had a boyfriend in a
different high school
but he wasn't at our high school so i
didn't feel bad
because like we never dated but we like
would always make out before and after
like theater stuff this is another
person
who's also in the dance program so at
this point you kind of tell it
jay and then there was another thing
where there was a private school about
20 minutes away
and they had like they were like this is
gonna sound misogynistic and it was
uh they had like the girls
we like looked down on our high school
peers
because we saw them every day and so we
were like oh we want like these new
private school girls and so they were
like excursions
into like forbidden private school
territory where we like
i went to a dance with one of those
girls and then we got back to like
people at our school like well jay where
are you doing going
we don't even why do you care so much
about those girls i was like why do
y'all
care so much about what i do in my free
time yeah
yeah i'm sorry that i'm making friends
that i'm a person of the world
yeah yeah i'm a boy about mississippi
yeah i don't i don't want to hang out
i see y'all every day i know how poorly
y'all do on english exams i don't want
to have to deal with this
it uh we've talked a lot on the podcast
about like
the reputations other schools in your
area would have
and like what that meant because there
was a private school close to my
school too and i feel like if you're a
public school kid
the nearest private school is
immediately sexy no matter what's going
on there
it's like also like drug fueled because
like
because you hear about that stuff
because one of my friends
definitely got expelled for selling
drugs but like whenever i thought about
drugs in my school i was like yeah but
like
these are like boring drugs like what's
going on
over there i always imagine their drugs
are like
one of them uh like opens up a book and
it's like in there
like it's like like cruel intentions
like she's got it
oh yeah we all yeah all of us watches
boslerman's
like romeo plus juliet like we all like
what kind of ecstasy do they have over
there
yes they have they the
private school kids always had like a
very sexy aura
and then the other public schools would
have different reputations like there
was another nearby public school that i
thought had more
punk street cred than our school and i
thought had cuter punk boys than our
school
i could see that i could see that i was
a big
i was a big fan of
private school like parties
too because i lived far away from my
high school i only went to my high
school because
of the theater program and because my
mom worked for the school district so
i got like an automatic transfer and so
like i would have gone
to a different high school
if it hadn't been for like all of those
extinguishing circumstances
and what was that like what was that
high school's deal would it would have
changed your life
yes it would have been no
i would not be who i am today
i don't think i'd be in new york i don't
think i'd be doing comedy
it just the the foundation in the
bedrock of the jay jordan
that america knows and loves will be
fundamentally shifted so
wow it is crazy to think about like
little things from
middle school or high school like little
just like shifts like because your mom
worked here and you went to the school
you did this and had access to this
that legitimately changes the course of
your
life oh yeah and also like i wasn't
there was no way for me to articulate
what being bi or like queer meant in
high school
so i had two friends that
looked like a lot of my exes and looking
back on
it but then there also were a couple of
instances
where i definitely told myself there was
one time
where there's this like there's there's
always a guy
okay so i have never dated someone who
works for a restaurant
but i have like flirted with
a boy in high school who ended up
becoming a chef and i feel like
i i saw it and i like this guy early
because yeah but we were like
laying all over each other in theater
and like one of our teachers was like
you can't do that and i was like
in theater yeah um i'm sorry we're
actually working on something i was like
now we we prac and so we just was like
it was like
this level of intimacy between
two high school boys that i was not
aware of and i was just like well we
just
in the afternoons if we have some free
time we just go we go lay on each other
and just chill out why not
i i feel like that's also such a classic
like early
sexuality early high school thing where
it's like no i just have a friend and we
constantly have our hands down each
other's pants and we're
friends why are you my friend you being
so weird about
it yeah we're naked we're friends
and his name was chaz so i got a chaz
out of the way
as far as dating guys who were bad for
you
checklist that so yeah i was going to
ask like
did you have a concept of yourself as bi
at that time
or what okay there was there was no one
this is something that i am still
working on and figuring out how to
articulate
because my high school was very okay
with lesbians and by
lesbians i do mean our
multiple state championship winning
women's basketball team
so our basketball team lady mustangs
were so good
they defeated the homophobia so
there were people this is like early
2000s mississippi
what those girls do when they're not on
the court
they can play some ball we had like i
think they're like three people from
when i was there that are in the wnba
now
and so like they're like there were some
and so like there was
honestly a beautiful screenplay by the
way you gotta tuck that one away
that has um remember the titans energy
right so there was like a clear
like sexuality doesn't make anyone
good or bad their accomplishments their
achievements and
their dedication is what we choose to
focus on there was one aspect of that
that was for like lesbians and like sort
of non-gender non-conforming studs at my
high school
but then there was no queer male
representation
and so like i never was like oh i'm bi
i but i would say things like who's that
new kid he seems like he has
some really cool stories and i feel like
we need to be nicer to this new kid
who is handsome objectively we
we've all agreed that he's a handsome
looking dude uh
we're talking about it we're thinking
about it everyone's thinking about it
so if he's gonna get to read the hamlet
stuff today can
i read the horatio stuff and not did
i just because you know because they
were close
yeah and i want him to feel welcome at
the school
yeah and you guys need to do a better
job at welcoming him to school like see
like we don't know where he's from what
his parents do for a living
like when were you born we don't know
any of this stuff
i'm just talking questions um so that
was like the extent of it for me
yeah i feel i i am vibing with what
you're saying because i feel like
at my school there was a big trend of
girls being bi like in the early 2000s
girls could be by and it was very sexy
for them to be bi
you know who did that i don't i don't
want to say this is
i wonder i wonder if we're going to say
the same thing so
are you going to say tattoo tattoo
i was going to say misha barton and
olivia wilde
on the oc i
listen the oc ruined me too because i
don't think
anyone i don't think anyone
oh my god because he looks like an x2
seth cohen
there has never been someone who i was
like man
oh man we should be in good friends
he um i remember
watching the episode where he stands on
the kissing booth
and tells uh summer summer acknowledge
me now
or lose me forever and i started crying
man
you know what i think poor riot because
we're nobody watching that show for him
i i have one friend who's like i loved
ryan and i'm like you missed the point
you missed the point
i had a crush on peter gallagher before
i had a crush
on the main character of the year
absolutely
absolutely luke even no i didn't like
luke
what else like i'm trying to think of
like if there were any other like
telltale signs when i got into a big
fight my senior prom with my date
afterwards i went to my best friends
they were twins i went to their house
and i was like man why can't it just be
like this just the boys
we don't need stupid girls on prom night
and then one of them was like i'm gonna
go
have sex with my girlfriend but yeah jay
uh and so i was like why can't we just
watch
the phoenix suns versus the san antonio
spurs and have a good time
with the homies without all these chicks
running
and girls starting fights that i
probably also started but you know what
when you're in high school everyone else
is wrong and you're right
okay let's look through some of these
photos that you said
okay get let's get the full picture of
teen j
now oh that was okay this is like so
this is my good friend christian vance
who did play football
this is us probably at 14 15 this is
definitely freshman
sophomore year of high school that was
so i think brian brian dawkins who is on
the left of this picture that's like a
kobe jersey
so like we were still wearing like
basketball jerseys and
that was like a big deal because i'm
wearing a button up and it's because
like jay-z started wearing button-ups
and i was like i'm be like jay-z so i
wore a button-up
and that's a button-up i wanna say from
the gap maybe it was blue
and white like a gingham pattern
uh it had a fresh lineup for this photo
yeah those those are the homies i have
like a wrap a little
baby wrap group with those two well
i mean first of all this would have been
a perfect like
cover for your cd like this would have
been amazing
i what i love about this picture is i
feel like all three of you look like
such babies but you can tell that you
like
think you look like a girl oh oh we
think we
we thought we were killing it yes
and i will say that it's like three very
distinct and slick
fashion looks are being presented but
you
are babies and you especially your
friend in the middle the way he's
looking at the camera is like oh
christian christian christina is
one of number one he's one of the people
who like
oh my god it's so funny to me because
whenever you do comedy you're always
like who's the person
who isn't doing comedy now but i swear
there would be one of the funniest
people
like to ever do like a podcast and
christian is one of those people
there were like times in high school
where i knew i was gonna get in trouble
because of him
one at one point he
it was at the end of the school day and
so like we were like all
leaving and he like ran
and i was like what's wrong and he like
was mooning everyone
as he ran because he knew if he ran his
he had his pants down a little bit
and his shirt was up and the teachers
couldn't catch him a teacher tried to
run and catch him and
couldn't it's like that's
that's the kind of in high school if
someone does that you go aw man
that's legendary yeah we will never
forget i'm talking about it now and i'm
in my exactly here you are
here here you are we're talking about it
now and i
even like i've been doing comedy for a
long time i've seen some
really [ __ ] funny people do really
funny stuff
but i have never like the way that i've
laughed watching someone like [ __ ]
around
in high school like where you would
actually be crying so much that it's
hurting you oh i oh my god there are so
many things i cannot
at least just because i want people to
like me on this podcast there's so many
things that i cannot say that we did
there's so many i am
i'm trying to think of one safe to tell
story okay
so one time we were in the hall and
like this was like after i don't know
how to describe it but like
the high school like became super
militant because we had like a new
principle and a new vice principle
and they weren't going to take any of
our crap
and they had new hall passes and like
things were like getting way stricter
and so me and the girl who i ended up
going to senior prom with were in the
height we're in the hallway
and we were just kind of like talking
and i had a hall pass and she didn't and
the vice principal
was like you two what's what's going on
i was like she
is in the hall without the hall pass i'm
going to the bathroom
and just like got her in trouble i never
i'll never forget
so i was like that's what you get
well i'm actually fine so bye i was like
uh officer
have you was did your high school like
was there a lot of like shenanigans
going on that caused them to
like crack down yeah because we went
from having like a
cool principle to having like an
ex-military principal
and then like one of his vice principals
got bumped up to principal because then
he retired
and she was like no nonsense but then
like she tried to be cool
our senior year and we were like weren't
you the lady
who like yelled at us for the last three
years
all right let's look at the la the last
little bit of these photos because i
know we've got some more
oh we do we definitely have some more so
this was like when i won an award
uh i was part of these were like a lot
of ap
kids the girl who went to prom with my
senior year is definitely in this photo
um she's somewhere she's somewhere
in the photo i'm friends i'm still
friends with a few of these people
so this was a good group because this
was like all of the homies
christian as you could tell he's like
right behind me
this is i like wore a tie because we had
to dress up that day
and like to me that meant thai so i'm
kind of crushing this photo i'm not i
wasn't you know i'm not one of those
people who's like man i was killing it
but i was
killing it in this photo my two best
friends stand
out and like you're commanding the photo
you also have like a side clearly and
you're giving it to
the camera uh my
two best friends eric and evan are in
the back at the
at the top eric in the green evan and
the white eric was like
the one that had like game but evan was
secretly
the more handsome one so there was
always like a little bit of fight
when girls were like who was hotter out
of the two of them because
girl cause cause girls would be like
my heart says one thing i mean
first of all i was constantly convincing
myself that i was in an episode of the
oc when i was in high school so
i was always creating this stuff where i
would be like i have two guy best
friends and we could be best friends
or i could turn it into something deeply
toxic
courtney my friend courtney is down here
this is actually courtney's photo she
sent it to me
uh and she's down in the pink with the
red uh
with like the red skirt courtney was a
cheerleader gymnast she went to duke
courtney was like one of my homegirls
but courtney was also the first person
to be like jay
are you gay and i was like courtney
no why you want to hook up she's like no
i do not want to hook up with you jay
i'm trying to help you
i don't
that was like we had that conversation i
want to say three times before i
actually
like told her i was bi because i was
like no
cory come on courtney what you talking
about
uh but that's a good friend good friend
a good friend
i um this photo is like on the stairwell
so like there used to be a stairwell for
like the main floor
and then you could go up these uh these
stairs
to get to like where your classes were
junior or senior year
because your classes sophomore year and
like freshman year were in the freshman
wing and then kind of on the base
because they didn't want them going up
and down the stairs i don't know
there was always stuff like that it was
like once you're a sophomore you can go
up the stairs
and it's like okay at least one time
i want to say i was like probably 15 and
we'll say i
i was because that's in sync with the
podcast
i fell down these stairs oh god
just ruined the day it ruined my day it
happened it happened after lunch i
definitely had a good day going because
i don't know where the confidence
to not pay attention going down these
stairs i just fell down the stairs like
this is it
and did people see yes everyone saw
we were all in the hallway i went by
myself
horrible i still think about that i have
stress dreams about falling down those
stairs
that is that is one of those experiences
in like middle school that
will like you'll never forget oh you'll
be like
i will never forget this boy austin
telling me there's something on
whispering to me there's something on
your skirt and it was the first time i
ever
got my period on like a piece of
clothing oh no no
no like i hear i hear him saying there's
something on your skirt in
my nightmares oh no
can i tell you like the worst
okay when we were in fifth grade
one of my classmates got her period
and because we were not adults
the teacher sent all of the boys out
to go like play to have like a
discussion with the girls
about what it what this kind of stuff
means
and like one of my guy friends
because keep in mind i've been going to
school with these people some of these
people since
fourth and fifth grade that i was in
high school with and we're dealing with
mississippi public schools yeah correct
yes yes
so one of my friends was like man i hope
a girl gets a period every day if we get
a free recess
um i literally the all i can think about
is this poor girl getting her period and
then like the entire day is disrupted
and they're like she's like all the boys
were sent outside all of the girls have
to have a meeting and
yeah we were not gonna be reading i
think what were we
focusing on like the devil's arithmetic
it was it was like an english class
yeah this white house but you know
what um while we're here what sex ed if
any did you get
sex ed are you kidding me
in mississippi in mississippi
sex ed is them saying you remember when
veronica was here
last semester but she's not
i took ap bio though so we like had to
discuss sexuality
not sexuality but like the gametes and
like uh sexual organs in a very
professional way in like
ap bio was 11th grade and so mr powell
at one point brian dawkins who you saw
in a photo
he asked mr pop mr powell he was like
are blue balls real
[Laughter]
he just straight up asked it and the
rest of class was
like
he's like blue balls aren't real what
this means is that
people get sexually frustrated and so
maybe your frustration you think it's
manifesting physically
and then brown was like but what about
blue he was like well brian
on some older white men
some of the veins show more
prominently in the scrotum
so that's where it comes it was a very
like
it was an honest it's a good explanation
but like
at that point as high schools i was like
we were like ready for like
an answer and he just told us the truth
gross
yeah just like very soberly was like
well actually scientifically no yeah
all right let's see which other ones we
have okay
oh let's see what is this we got we got
an iconic look we got a popped collar
on the green polo and i'm pretty sure is
a lacoste polo or it might be a ralph
lauren
with a pink horse i don't know i can't
tell because over it i'm wearing a polo
hoodie
wearing the hood uh the jeans are
definitely from
abercrombie or hollister i can tell from
the wash yes
a classic 2000s and i have on a white
t-shirt underneath
the polo so this is i'm doing a lot of
stuff wrong
but i'm doing a lot of stuff right for
the time period
the collar the green collar popping out
of the hoodie
is really special i was
honestly this is a serve and a stunt i'm
stunting
hard yeah and honestly the girl the girl
next to you looks like she's feeling it
she's looking
at you oh yeah yeah uh i want to say
that this is
i know who this is this is hadassah this
was in theater
this is in one of the theater classes i
don't know what we were doing
i was watching a scene probably i'd
assume
yeah listening but yeah uh you know what
let's say this is probably 2005. i was
curious this quality of photo says 2005
yeah
when we all had like a giant like
digital camera
and we would go to an event and you
would take a hundred photos of nothing
and upload
all of them to facebook yeah upload all
of them
you wouldn't even be like oh let's like
wait and just upload the ones with
people it'd be like all of these photos
need to be up now
yeah yeah and some of that many
duplicates it doesn't matter
like hundreds of photos of the same
evening
all right let's move okay oh oh this is
very slick here
this is gotta be junior year once again
we're talking 1516
because those are like younger girls
than us this is like gerard
michael terry michael terry was like a
soccer superstar
gerard who has his head down he was he
was a football superstar he was the
running back that
won us our like game our like
opening game senior year
and like ran and then just like kept
running
like like on like to in the game
and so we are at a restaurant that is
probably nothing nice
and the reason i'm looking like this i
can tell you what exactly
there was like a person who i was
beefing with hard at this event
because in high school sometimes they'd
invite people to places you because this
is this had to be after i had a car
because
we're just going wherever we wanted to
go and so like i was looking at the
table of people i was like why the [ __ ]
are you here
i was like why the [ __ ] is this person
at this party that we try to have
yeah it's high school and real
housewives are very similar in that way
where it's like why do you like you
would invite someone to your party who
you hated
so that you could fight with them at the
party oh so you could be like what the
[ __ ] are you doing here
like i oh didn't think you'd show up
except i knew that you were gonna be
here we had
but like the uh i wanna say
the two girls in this photo like erica
and orchid i
i think that was i think that's who that
is they were like younger than us so
this is also
i don't use this word in a way that is
dangerous
but like the predatory habits of
older high school boys when they started
inviting sophomore
girls to stuff because they have a car
that's what was going on because i
remember being like
we got to drive these girls they can't
drive
last year you couldn't drive i was like
yeah but you know it's
different the age differences seemed so
huge though oh yeah like it seemed like
such a world away for someone to be a
freshman and you're a junior when really
it's like
two years but also there's a puberty
there's puberty in those two years
well in mississippi they put a lot of
hormones in food so everyone's gone
through it by middle school
that's true fifth grade is early for
that girl to have gotten her
i'm not lying
all right so i feel like we've come to
the end here this
has been such a great episode
we end every episode with this question
so jay
if you could talk to team jay today
what would you tell him i would tell him
develop better time management skills
because in 2020 you're gonna have a lot
of free time on your hands that
you should have been more productive
with i i would also
say uh don't
pressure yourself into like having a
perfect high school experience
especially senior prom because high
school is
just going to be messy and sloppy no
matter what
and
maybe try a little harder at math that's
it
yeah maybe learn you know maybe learn a
little math
just a little a tiny amount
yeah just to just to get by but then
again we all have calculators in our
pockets anyway so who cares yeah jay
it's been so great having you on the
show you
are a true delight and for everyone
listening at home this has been the
roast of your teenage self podcast
you